I welcome to this video what what was
the lyrics again we are all in a yellow
submarine or something like that not
exactly a but but close okay let's see
the f3 line I'm going 4 p-5 that's an
interesting variation leading to very
very sharp positions okay going back the
main problem is to remember my own head
open analysis ah cheeks and then g6 b5
is hanging which irritates me a little
bit I still think it's right hmm yeah
that's so that's a typical problem you
kind of know what you do but you forget
what to do even if it's from a book that
you have written yourself yeah okay well
Knight f3 looks kind of normal okay
that's a that's a risky move for sure
okay you first think later so after
Queen edge for he wants to move the King
right he has to move the king
you can also do this by the way yeah
let's do this first maybe he's
blundering Bishop c4 for Queen age four
and otherwise I'm winning the d5 pawn
it's also not bad white really has
nothing out nothing developed Wow okay
check wait let's let's just think for
one moment this is really right but it
already looks very very shaky Bishop a6
looks very normal yeah is probably right
what is moving that again what is your
move now
we you want me to come I had to move the
other night yeah okay checkmate yeah
that was a successful opening result for
once okay I think we should be five is a
little bit much I don't think he can can
afford that really the normal move is
Knight f3 and then I think nights is
seven if i'm not mistaken but i tend to
forget get stuff this is this is already
very very difficult this is hanging jack
yeah blunders this piece and where are
you going probably back and then i can
take and well whitis has no development
and it doesn't look good simply doesn't
this I believe shouldn't shouldn't be
Jack shouldn't be holding yet it's minus
minus seven ok ok so here how do I win
their first taking and then rook e8 yeah
there is some point to that right taking
here and then you're only two na troop D
aid after which Queenie one is still
somewhat somewhat hooding yeah here I'm
just winning out with rookie five yeah
this is whole line it's very dangerous
it is nowadays quite popular yeah why it
is really behind in development it has
an exposed King in the center but he has
a big center it's just super sharp but
at the moment black is yeah willing is
on very nicely this is some examined in
my book ok I hope you like that quick
one thanks for watching